Wir machen heute was kleines, und zwar bauen wir heute endlich mal so ein kleines Bash-Skript
zusammen für die Hintergründe. Und dann uploaden wir das Ganze auf GitHub und erwähnen natürlich
auch den Rackman, dass die Bilder alle von ihm sind. Machen wir mal kurz die VM an. Also
wir uploaden das alles auf ShitHub. Ich bin plötzlich mal ganz sicher, Google Drive, wo ich
es habe. Drive, was ist das hier? Ja, das sieht gut aus. White Paper Happy Time. Mal umsortieren,
Firefox aufmachen. Mal updaten, weil es ist Archlinux, es hat immer Updates. Weißt du?
Ach, ich dachte es hat immer Updates. So, was wir jetzt machen ist folgendes. Wir laden uns
die ganzen Backgrounds runter. Wie geht denn das hier? Wie kann man alles runterladen? So,
wir laden uns die ganzen Backgrounds runter und dann basteln wir einen Skript,
was irgendwie so anhand der Tageszeit die Backgrounds ändert und das war's. Irgendwie
gescheit ist nicht dieses komische Ding, was letztens da Chat-GPT ausgespuckt hat.
Ja, ich kann ja schon mal das Bizzar Stream richtig angelaufen ist. Ich kann ja schon mal
das GitHub Projekt machen. Shithub. Ist das ein Fiveheader Projekt oder ist es ein Wubblos
Projekt? Ich glaube, das ist ein Wubblos Projekt. WallpaperChamp. Wie nennen wir es denn? White
People Happy Desktop. Irgendwie sowas, oder? White People Happy Desktop Backgrounds. Wie
schreibt man das jetzt am besten? For every time of day, oder irgendwie sowas? Everyone. Irgendwie
sowas. Desktop Read Me License. Ja, Rackmann, welche License gibt denn das Ganze? Creative
Commons. Oh fuck. Zero Universal. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Wir lassen erst mal keine
Lizenz. Da können sich die Leute eigentlich offiziell gar nicht benutzen. Ja, ich kann
das nicht bestimmen. Ich hab die Bilder ja nicht gemacht. Okay. Yes. Repos. Das ist
Lizenz technisch eh nicht safe, aber da hast du wohl recht. Naja. Jetzt endlich wird's
kein Mensch interessieren. Okay. Wo haben wir die Sachen hier? Wurden die grad schon runtergeladen?
Nee, oder? Sag. Safe. Auf geht's. Von different daytimes. Ja, genau. Sowas in der Richtung. Wir
machen dann einfach die Bilder. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man gescheit die Bilder in... Hat
jemand mal eine GitHub-Readme gemacht mit irgendeiner Galerie oder sowas? Nee, ich glaub nicht.
Ich glaub, weiß gar nicht, ob es das geht. Ich mein, das ist ein Marktau und das kann alles
mögliche HTML. Wird schon funktionieren. Leute, morgen ist Feiertag, hab ich festgestellt. Guckt
mal. War mir neu. Ich mein, für mich ist es egal, weil... Naja, ich muss montags eh nicht arbeiten.
Irgendwie hab ich das jetzt erst gecheckt, dass morgen Feiertag ist.
Hast du dann drei Tage next week oder dadurch den Nachteil? Nee, ich hab nen Nachteil dadurch.
Nachteil, wenn du es so willst, ja. Der freie Tag ist verschenkt, also jeder hat Montag frei,
ich auch. Jaja, ich hab ganz normal vier Tage Woche. Ja, das trifft an 1-2 Tagen im Jahr zu,
damit kann ich leben. Jaja, ich hab nen Nachteil. Wie fällt dann Weihnachten dieses Jahr?
Wann ist Weihnachten 2023? Ok, Freitag. Montag? Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Alter, das fällt ja mal richtig beschissen, ey.
Haha, das fällt ja mal mega scheiße, Alter.
Oh, das fällt ja mal richtig kacke.
Okay, das ist mies, das ist ja mal richtig mies, Alter.
Das fällt auch noch auf Montag, Mann.
Oh, das ist ja mal mega beschissen, Alter.
Ja, gut, gibt's Schlimmeres.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, das ist wirklich super, ganz furchtbar schrecklich, wieso ist das
kacke?
Weil ich Montags immer frei hab und ich ja deswegen nicht mehr und mehr bekomme.
Übrigens, guck mal, was ich gefunden habe auf Shithub vorhin.
Beste, ein Plants vs. Zombies Widescreen Mod.
Ich würde sagen, es ist mal wieder Zeit für neues Playthrough, allerdings diesmal mit
Widescreensupport.
Ich weiß übrigens nicht, wie lange es das schon gibt, anscheinend auch nicht so lange.
Widescreen Modge.
Das ist ein Game, das muss ich eigentlich so einmal alle 1-2 Jahre mal wieder durchspielen.
Das geht ja auch schnell, das hast du in 4-5 Stunden durch, das Gesamt.
Das ist ja tatsächlich so wahnsinnig, also gut, vielleicht 10 Stunden, wenn du alles
so die Sachen noch anlocken willst, aber...
Written in Rust? Nee, glaube ich nicht, das ist Written in...
Moment, warum ist das Written in Rust?
Okay, das schreibt irgendwelche Bites an irgendwelche Hex Offsets.
Na ja gut, ich weiß nicht, ob das unbedingt Written in Rust sein müsste.
Macht eigentlich relativ wenig Sinn, Written in Rust zu sein, oder?
Das patcht ja nur, das bringt ja keine Custom-Logik rein.
Also insofern war keine Ahnung, was das für einen Sinn macht.
Nun gut, wie dem auch sei...
Ich hab's zumindest heute entdeckt und ich dachte mir, es ist mal wieder Zeit für ein Replay.
Geht das mit der Origin-Version?
Oh, sorry, sorry, der EA-App-Version?
Wahrscheinlich.
Wobei, ich hab's, glaube ich, auch mittlerweile auf Steam.
Ich glaube, ich hab's auf allen Plattformen, die es gibt.
Ich hab's sogar auf der Xbox.
Wisst ihr, ich würde mich bei dem Spiel wirklich über den zweiten Teil freuen.
Den zweiten Teil, der halt auch den Namen verdient hat.
Der zweite Teil war halt ganz okay, aber auch schon komplett verschissen mit Microtransactions und allem.
Das ist echt so ein Paradebeispiel.
Wieder mache aus einem ganz guten, kleinen, netten Game irgendeinen Microtransaction Monster.
So einen richtig guten zweiten Teil, der einfach das macht, was der erste Teil gut gemacht hat.
Plus halt einfach noch mehr Levels und alles drum herum.
Ich glaube, es würde jeder feiern.
Aber der zweite Teil war halt Microtransaction versackt.
Zwei Reihen Sonnenblumen und Abfahrt, ja.
Wobei das beste Setup in Plants vs. Zombies ja immer noch das mit den Pilzen ist.
Das da.
Also für Leute, die noobs sind und die bisschen interaktiv was machen wollen, ist das Setup ganz nice.
Oder aber man kann auch Endlos bauen, man kann auch Endless bauen.
Das sieht man im, ne Moment, das ist noch nicht das Endless Bild.
Das ist das komplette Endless Bild.
Und das ist wirklich nahezu, nahezu, das ist immer noch nicht das Endless Bild.
Die, die Garlix kommen noch weg oder?
Ja, anscheinend doch nicht.
Es gibt, es gibt so ein Endless, so ein Endless, das hier meine ich.
Das hier meine ich.
Das kann man, das muss man aber alles anlockt haben.
Wobei die weißen Pilze sind, glaube ich, diese, die man anlocken kann.
Das muss man aber alles anlockt haben.
Wobei die weißen Pilze sind, glaube ich, diese Kopie, diese Kopie Pilze, ja.
Ja, das ist, das ist so das Endless Setup.
Da ist da alles dabei, was du brauchst.
Und das kannst du mehr oder weniger Endless laufen lassen.
Manchmal backt das rum, wenn dieser, dieser Michael Jackson Zombie mit, ne Moment.
Ne, wenn dieser Zombie mit der Box kommt und der umkippt und das dann hier explodiert vorne.
Dann ist es nicht wirklich Endless, aber das geht nah, nahezu Endless.
Das ist aber dann schon ein bisschen advanceder, wenn man das hier so sieht, ja.
Aber das müssen wir echt mal wieder spielen, hätte ich, hätte ich Bock drauf.
So.
Was macht mein Download?
Download.
Drive, Download.
So, und das soll nach...
Repos.
White.
Peepo.
Happy.
Clear.
Was?
Was mache ich hier?
Clear minus L.A.
Ja.
Clear minus L.S.
Alles klar.
MK.
Dear.
Images.
Drive.
Download.
Nach Images.
Unzip.
So, und jetzt haben wir unsere ganzen White.
Peepo.
Happy.
Images.
So, und jetzt haben wir unsere ganzen White.
Peepo.
Happy.
Hier.
Und hier können wir jetzt den Skript reinhauen.
Touchsetbg.sh oder sowas.
Was die Images switcht.
Ja, also um euch das nochmal zu zeigen.
Der Rackman hat Hintergründe gebaut.
Für jede Tageszeit einen passenden Desktop-Hintergrund.
Wie kann man sich das anzeigen lassen?
Also guckt, seht ihr.
Man hat für jede Zeit einen passenden Desktop-Hintergrund.
Es gibt Sonnenuntergangs.
White.
Peepo.
Happy.
Die gucken natürlich Oldschool-Ultra-Skiller.
Dann gibt es das ganze nochmal, wo einfach nur die Sonne untergeht.
Dann gibt es den Sonnenaufgang.
Ne, das ist nochmal Sunset.
Der guckt immer noch.
Ach, das ist mit Planket und das andere ist Cozy.
Dann gibt es Sunrise.
Da putzt er Zähne.
Das ist nicht für jede Stunde.
So für jede Tageszeit hast du drin.
Das ist Sonnenaufgang.
Dann hast du jede Menge Bilder, wo er schläft.
Was heißt jede Menge?
Du hast gar nicht so viele.
Du hast die alle nur mit Mond und ohne Mond.
Da träumt er verschiedene Sachen.
Dann gibt es den noch Sonnenaufgang.
Dann gibt es noch Sonnenaufgang mit Futter.
Dann gibt es den noch tagsüber Mittagessen, Cookies, Futter und Arbeiten.
Das heißt wir bauen uns jetzt einen Skript,
was guckt von der Uhrzeit her, welche Uhrzeit es ist.
Und dann den Hintergrund setzt.
Die Hintergründe werde ich auch so hochladen.
Die kann sich auch jeder selbst scrapen.
Das Skript muss man dafür auch gar nicht benutzen.
Wie erfolgt der Abnahmetest des Skripts 24 Stunden?
Das dürft ihr dann ausprobieren.
Also wir machen irgendwie sowas von 6 Uhr ist Sunrise,
von 8 Uhr ist Morning, von 11 Uhr ist Tag,
ab 18 Uhr ist Sunset und ab 20 Uhr ist dann irgendwie Night.
Irgendwie sowas.
Und ab 21 Uhr ist Night.
Dann das mal alle Bilder auch eine Chance hat zu sehen.
Erstmal Scrum.
Na Moment, erstmal müssen wir unser Kanban Board,
unseren Scrum Master ernennen dafür.
Leute, wer hat Scrum Master?
Wer hat Agile Erfahrung von euch?
Jetzt müssen wir, jetzt machen wir es richtig.
Leute, Daily.
Okay, Ligat ist unser Scrum Master.
Der muss uns sagen, wenn wir das Agile Mindset nicht richtig einhalten.
Lasst es safe machen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ein Kanban Board sollten wir auf jeden Fall anlegen.
Ja, erstmal denke ich auch, erstmal ein Kanban Board erstellen.
Warum nicht das Ganze nach Sonnenstand, Mondstand?
Weil du dann irgendwie abfragen müsstest, wie der Sonnenstand, Mondstand ist.
Irgendwie auch passend zur Zeitzone und wo du auf der Erde bist.
Also gut, Zeitzone.
Das ist mir für den Bash Script ein bisschen zu kompliziert.
Aber du kannst ja selbst was bauen, wenn dir das zu billig ist.
Dann müsste ich ihn mal fragen, weiß ich grad nicht.
Da gibt es doch sicherlich ein Paket.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe keins gefunden, was tagesformabhängig Background setzen kann.
Und was dann auch anhand des Namens das rausfällt.
Ich meine, das kann jeder benutzen, wie er will.
Ich lade die Bilder ja hoch.
Eine coole Idee.
Aber das kackt halt ab, wenn man ins Internet geht.
Ich mache es jetzt erst mal Hardcoated.
Ihr könnt euch dann, wenn ihr wollt, am Bash-Skript auslassen.
Ich werde einfach Pull-Requests …
Plint Mergen.
Weil, der Chat macht ja prinzipiell kein Zaun.
Und wenn ich dann plötzlich die Plint Mergen-Technologien durante dem Video ablese,
dann muss man das auch nicht überprüfen.
Machen wir jetzt Kanban oder Scrum?
Wir machen beides, weil wir sind ja ein agiles T-Shaped-Team.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, hä?
Jetzt ist die Frage, wo habe ich die Music auf?
Da.
Scrum-Ban, genau.
Das ist eher Scrum-Ban.
Ok, Bash-Magic, Leute.
Bash-Magic-Time.
Ok, erst mal alles hinzufügen.
Ok, dann machen wir das jetzt.
Oh, die Bilder sind ganz schön groß.
Alter, wie fett sind bitte schön die Bilder.
Oh, das sind ordentlich pepo-fette Bilder.
Welche Auflösung haben die Bilder eigentlich?
Ich dachte die sind bloß 1080p, oder nicht?
Ach nee, das sind 4K-Bilder.
Eher noch viel geiler.
Ok, nice.
Da sind die ja sogar 4K-Certified.
Git LFS.
Quatsch, das wird einfach committed und gut ist.
Mir doch egal, das ist nicht mein Speicherplatz.
Ok.
Bin. Bash.
Ich weiß, manche schreien jetzt rum, oh es muss bin erst her.
Das ist mir egal, jeder hat eine Bash installiert.
So.
Wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit, Leute?
Wie machen wir das?
Ich muss da mal kurz überlegen.
Wie kriege ich denn jetzt eine Liste
mit allen meinen Files
hier zusammen?
Find.
So was.
Und dann irgendwie type F.
Ja, dann hat man es doch.
Und dann grab nach
xppo.
So, dann hat man die Bilder.
Nice. Ok.
Und dann sortieren,
dass es immer die gleichen Reihenfolge gibt.
Ok, das finde ich schon mal gut.
Das brauchen wir jetzt.
Files.
Gleich.
So.
Da haben wir jetzt unsere Bilder drinne.
Wir könnten
mit den Bildern auch NFTs
und einen Champ...
Ja, na klar.
Wie heißt diese Kryptobörse?
Da wo die alle ihre shit
NFTs verkaufen.
Aber ich hab's vergessen.
Wenn ich den Namen lese, weiß ich sofort wieder.
Und ich meine nicht, ich meine nicht.
Ja, genau
dieses Ding.
Ja, genau das meine ich.
Ich werde nie NFTs machen, Leute.
Der Hype ist ja auch schon ziemlich wieder vorbei.
Nee, ich meinte Dings hier.
Ich meinte Open Seas oder
Open CS oder
wie soll man das ausspricht?
So, hier haben wir unsere Files.
Jetzt
brauchen wir noch, was ist denn das nochmal?
Date
Date minus, nee
Was war das?
Date Prozent H?
Oder nee, plus
Plus ist es glaube ich.
Plus H, okay.
Also das ist die Stunde.
Date
Plus Prozent H.
Das müssen wir nicht checken.
Das hat jeder auf dem Rechner.
K.I.
K.I. ist jetzt der Hotshit.
Wen jucken NFTs?
Wen juckt Web 3.0 noch?
Hat jemand von euch Web 3.0
in den letzten paar Wochen, Monaten
mal gehört? Nee.
Da war nur A.I.
und nochmal A.I.
und A.I. in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Und vielleicht ein bisschen
Ausläufer von Blockchain
Kryptogramm noch.
Das ist ja immer so
ein bisschen Grundrauschen.
War das Web? Nee.
Ich glaube es war Web 3.0 oder?
Oder Web 3 war das?
War das?
Ich glaube es war Web 3.0
dieses ganze.
Allerdings muss ich ehrlich sagen
ich sehe es wie Erbsenraube, also
von den beiden Trends
ist mit dem Machine Learning Trend
auf jeden Fall lieber als
der ganze Krypto-Shit.
Was machen eigentlich diese ganzen
Krypto-Scam-Games, die immer so mit
super viel Hype verbunden waren.
Da ist doch noch kein einziges
rausgekommen. Da gab es doch dieses
Super-Scammy-Game.
Wie ist das? Earth?
Irgendwas mit Earth?
To Earth? Oder irgendwie
sowas? Second Earth?
Nee, das war Second Life.
Double Earth? Earth 2.0? Ich weiß nicht.
Dieses Ding, wo du
virtuell auf einer Karte
Länder kaufen konnt.
Ernsthaft? Wirklich?
Alter, das ist der größte Scam-Shit
überhaupt. Warum
hat man da Geld reingesteckt?
Krypto-Land.
Ja, den Shit gab es auch noch.
Ich glaube, mit den
meisten Sachen haben noch nicht mal die Erfinder-Geld
verdient.
Stimmt, was
macht eigentlich das Metaverse?
Was macht
eigentlich so das Metaverse?
Ja,
Spigge, White Paper Happy, was macht
eigentlich das Metaverse so?
Ja,
der Zuck, der
dreht halt immer noch am Rad.
Die Hälfte der Erwachsenen
weiß nicht, was das Metaverse
ist. Ich bezweifle, dass
die Leute, die andere
Hälfte ist wirklich weiß.
Das weiß glaube ich
Facebook selber noch nicht mal so richtig.
Die National Hockey League
hat eine Dynamic Metaverse
Experience in Roblox.
Ist das jetzt ne Verarschung oder
hat das wirklich jemand so geschrieben?
Eine Dynamische Metaverse in Roblox,
Roblox?
Man weiß es nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das weiß ich echt nicht.
Das weiß ich wirklich nicht.
Eine Metaverse in Roblox, Roblox?
Meine Güte.
Na gut, da hat irgend so ein komischer
BWL-Stonkstyp von denen gehört.
Jetzt drei Jahre nachdem es angesagt war.
Ha, Metaverse.
Oh, da müssen wir auch was machen.
Ja, das mein ich. Den Müll gibt's ja immer noch.
Außer dieses komische Video
gibt's ja da nix. Also das ist ja kein
Game oder sowas.
Die haben ja angefangen mit, es soll ein Game werden,
würde halt nie ein Game und wird auch nie ein Game.
Ist auch so eine Unreal
5 Demo wieder gewesen.
Wo sie mit irgend so einem Auto
durch irgendwie pre-rendert
äh, äh, nicht pre-rendert
Keine Ahnung, auto-generated
Weltgefahren sind
total unsinnig, alter.
Ja, goodluck.
Du chebatest uns doch eh.
Du hast wahrscheinlich gar nichts investiert da drinnen.
Scamverse, ja und von dieser
Richtung gab es ja noch total viel andere Sachen.
Ok, jetzt lasst uns mal ganz schnell mal
unseren Bash-Script, da gucken wir vielleicht noch ein paar Videos,
das sollte ja nicht allzu lang dauern.
Unserem Fiveheader
Bash-Script mit einem
Ähm
Wie kriegt man raus in einem
Bash-Script?
In welchem Verzeichnis das Script ist?
Äh, Bash
Get Script Directory
How do I get the directory where a Bash-Script is located?
Excellent.
Genau das brauche ich.
What?
Was ist das für
Magic?
Ok, meint ihr das funktioniert?
CD minus minus
Was?
Was macht CD minus minus?
Ach ne, Moment
Minus minus ist nur, dass danach keine
Optionen mehr kommen.
Ich glaube, deswegen ist minus minus.
Was anderes ergibt keinen Sinn.
So, und dann
DNA minus minus
Immer minus minus?
Warum immer minus minus minus?
Was macht er an der Stelle?
Was macht das denn?
Und vor allem, warum hat der Typ
Double Quotes in Double Quotes?
Nix, nix so geiles.
Na gut, okay, Echo Dear.
Guck mal, ob das funktioniert.
Moment, wenn ich das jetzt so richtig schreiben würde,
dann würde es auch vielleicht funktionieren.
CMOD plus X, ZBG.
ZBG.
Tatsächlich, es funktioniert.
Stack Overflow weiß einfach Bescheid.
Ich hab zwar keine Ahnung,
was es genau macht,
aber nice, okay.
Ultrabash Magic ist das.
Okay, while
true
do
done
sleep, okay.
Alle 5 Sekunden checken wir, ob eine neue Tageszeit ist.
Okay, also.
Dann lass uns das doch mal ausprobieren.
Was ist das?
Egal, haben wir doch schon.
Also, das heißt, wir gucken jetzt.
If
die Stunde
ist
größer als
machen wir es einfach von oben nach unten.
Die Stunde ist größer als
20,
dann
Okay.
So, wenn die Stunde größer als 20 ist
äh, nicht die Stufe.
Wenn die Stunde größer als 20 ist,
dann ist es
Nacht?
Moment, Bash, Bashcomments sind so,
gell?
Äh, Moment, äh, größer als, also,
also ab 21 Uhr ist Nacht.
Das ist doch ganz okay.
Ab 21 Uhr ist Nacht.
Das ist doch, das ist doch in Ordnung.
Kann man, kann man doch sagen.
So, das nächste ist, sagen wir,
ab 18 Uhr, ab 18 Uhr
ist Sunset.
Sagt, wenn es keinen Sinn macht,
was ich eingebe.
So, dann sagen wir,
ab, ab wann ist Mittag,
beziehungsweise ab wann ist Tag,
ab,
ab 11,
day,
ähm,
ab 8,
ab 8 ist
ab 8 ist Sunrise
und als letztes brauchen wir noch
Elz und das ist Nacht.
Ergibt das
Sinn? Ich hoffe,
dass ergibt Sinn.
So, dann gucken wir mal kurz wie wir den Background
setzen.
Wie mache ich das denn hier?
BG Phil.
Images.
Coffee.
Ja, funktioniert.
Okay.
Auer ist da hinter, du könntest auch...
Ja, das könnte ich wahrscheinlich machen.
Da hast du recht.
Wisst ihr was? Wir fragen danach mal,
wenn wir fertig sind,
fragen wir mal JetKPT, ob
sie das Bash Script
optimieren und
das BG Phil
verbessern kann.
Mal gucken, ob da was
sinnvolles bei rauskommt.
So, ich würde sagen,
jetzt müssen wir an der Stelle
das mal testen. Welcher Fall trifft denn jetzt zu?
Größer 17 Uhr trifft zu.
Also, jetzt müssen wir
das Background
setzen und das Background,
wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Also das hier ist...
Das hier ist Sunset.
Okay.
Wir müssen jetzt
von dem Ordner, in dem das Skript liegt
random
ein Image rauspicken.
Also, das ist schon mal
Blödsinn, das muss schon mal so rum.
Und an die Stelle muss
dir.
Okay, random
Image rauspicken, das hatten wir
letzten schon mal. Echo
Files
Nach
Ne, jetzt müssen wir erstmal die Bilder
rausfiltern,
die wir haben wollen, was mit Sunset
Also, die Dinger heißen dann sowas wie
Max
Underscore
Sunset
Holen wir mal aus hier
Sort
Images
Ne, Moment
Sunset
Ja, also die Dinger heißen sowas wie
So
Also
Ironic
Oops
Ich glaube
Kleines ist
Großes
Ist die Zahl
Und kleines ist die Geschichte mit AM und PM
Aber bin mir aus dem Kopf nicht sicher
So jetzt haben wir unsere Files
Das habe ich mir gemerkt
Das haben wir nämlich in dem letzten
Wallpaperscript
Ähm
Alter
Das Shuffle minus eins brauchen wir
Das habe ich mir gemerkt
Ja Shuffle
Ja weil ich es mir so gut gemerkt habe
Musste ich jetzt nachgucken
Logisch
So File gleich
So ok jetzt schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert
Dollar File
So wenn ich das jetzt ausführe
Sollte erst einen Hintergrund setzen
ZBG
Hahaha
Ok doch nicht so viel
Bash aus dem Kopf
Wo ist das Problem?
Synthax Error
Near Else If
Zeile 11
Äh was ist da falsch?
Ach Moment
Da muss glaube ich was drinne stehen
Glaub sonst geht das nicht
Wenn da nichts drinne steht
Kann das sein?
Glaub das geht nicht wenn da nichts drinne steht
Ok nice
Funktioniert
Ok
Pogu
Also die Logik
Die Logik ist schonmal ok die ich hier gebaut hab
Musst du nicht den alten Prozess noch killen?
Doch, aber der läuft ja nicht mehr
Im Hintergrund, den breche ich ja immer ab
Erst wenn ich den beim Desktop starten
Anmache oder so
Dann, dann schon
So also jetzt nimmt er hier
Random, random nen File
Ich würd sagen das lagern wir mal in ne Funktion aus
Nennen wir das mal sowas wie
SetBackGround
Äh, so
Und jetzt
Kopieren wir einfach
Den Krempel da rein
So
Sunset
So und das ist nicht hier
Wollen wir nicht Sunset sondern Dollar
Eins, weil dann können wir das
Hier ein bisschen schöner machen, da können wir jetzt
An der Stelle sagen
Set
Background
Moment das ist Bash, das ist Bash
Sunset
So und hier können wir dann sagen
Night
Moment wir haben Night doppelt
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Ok, lass mal kurz überlegen
Das hier ist
Day
Ich hab Morning vergessen oder?
Ich glaube ich hab Morning
Ja ich hab Morning vergessen
Pepega
Ach hier, ne hier ist doch Morning
Night Sunset Day Morning
Wummet brauch ich die Night überhaupt?
Es jetzt fehlt aber Sunrise
Ne, ich hab Morning vergessen
Und ich hab Morning vergessen
Es jetzt fehlt aber Sunrise
Moment jetzt fehlt aber Sunrise
Ich bin verwirrt
Wir brauchen noch eins
Wir brauchen noch so was wie
Keine Ahnung ab 6 Uhr oder sowas
Ab 6 Uhr ist Sunrise
Stimmt ich brauch zweimal Nacht
Das ist richtig ja ja ich brauch
Zweimal Nacht
Kann ich nicht
Kann ich nicht an
Judd Dixon sagen
Oder
Ist
Less
Or equal 5
Jetzt müsste ich doch
Alles abgedeckt haben
Weil ich mir da nicht
Sicher bin in meiner
In der Logik
Also
Wenn es größer als
Ab 21 Uhr
Und vor
Inklusive 5 Uhr
Ja doch
Das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren
Ab 6 Uhr dann das
Dann das, dann das, dann das
Nee doch
Eigentlich
Eigentlich habe ich glaube ich jetzt alles abgedeckt
Ja
Funktioniert
So jetzt müssen wir nur noch einstellen
Dass er
Das nicht
Nee nee nee er soll nicht alle 5 Sekunden random
In neues Background setzen
Das müssen wir jetzt einstellen
Denn
Wenn du
Wenn du die
Wenn du Night nicht
In Els machst musst du beim Anpassen
Nur einmal die Stundenangabe für
Morning ändern
Was?
Die Aua muss noch in die
Schleife
Oh das ist richtig
Sonst
Sonst funzt das nicht
Ja
Okay
Cron-Shop bei jeder vollen Stunde
Doch, doch geht auch, aber es soll ja
Es soll ja schneller gehen
Kann jeder machen wie er will
So jetzt müssen wir noch checken, dass die Datei
Kannste auch damit machen
Jetzt müssen wir noch checken, dass die Datei
Ähm
Älter als 15 Minuten ist
Dann machen wir mal
Alle 15 Minuten kann er das Bild ändern
So, da weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht
Also wenn du Morning zu einer anderen
Uhrzeit einstellen willst
Musst du das an zwei Stellen machen
Wieso?
Ich will Morning
Ab wenn es größer ist als
Sag mal ein Beispiel
Mach mal ein Beispiel, wo funktioniert es nicht
Wo würde es nicht funktionieren?
Im Ohr und im Creator 5
Ach wenn ich das ändern will
Ja
Ach so ja
Ja ja wenn ich das ändern will muss ich es da und da ändern
Ja
Ist halt so
Man könnte hier oben Variablen machen
So nach dem
Morning, Start oder irgendwie
Warum
So das funktioniert
Jetzt müssen wir noch kurz gucken
Wie kriegt man
Bash, File, Older
Than, ja genau One Hour
Das will ich haben
Unit Test
Das könnt ihr dann alles machen
What about Min Time?
Das ist mir schon viel zu kompliziert
Five Minutes
Ok
Beste
If, Test, Find, Min
Excellent, das brauchen wir
Uns das denn auch
Tests
Gucken wir mal
Tests und zwar
PBG
Es ist nicht älter als
30 Minuten, aber es sollte älter als eine Minute sein
Korrekt, funktioniert, nice
Eats
Also dann gucken wir hier
If
Das ist älter
als 15 Minuten
Dann machen wir das, ansonsten
machen wir das nicht, da können wir noch
Echo rein machen, irgendwie
Echo, irgendwie was weiß ich
Set new
Background to
Irgendwie sowas
Dollar File
So
Und jetzt sollte es das nur alle
15 Minuten machen
Dann testen wir noch mal, ob das funktioniert
So
Initial
Ach ne, er setzt es jetzt auch
Initial nicht, das ist natürlich
Doof
Ok, wie können wir das machen, dass er
Initial einmal beim
Starten das Build setzt
Wir könnten, ich hab ne Idee
Wir könnten sowas machen
Wie
TimeOutMinit
Das fängt mit 0 an
Aber das ist gut hier
So machen wir das
$TimeOutMin
Und nach dem ersten Durchlauf
Das ist zwar
TimeOutMin
Gleich 15
Ok, jetzt sollte er beim ersten Mal
Starten den Build setzen
Nice
Und für 15 Minuten nichts mehr machen
Einfach vor dem Schleifenlauf
Ja ne, dann müsste ich ja gucken, welche Zeit
Shega, danke schön für den Sub
Du du du du du
Du du du du
Ok
Ich würde sagen
Chat, ich würde sagen
Das
Das war's
Achso
Wie heissen die Dinger mit dem Mond
Die will ich, ups
Die mit dem Mond will ich nicht dabei haben
Minus
Moon
No Moon
Ok, die crepten wir raus
CREP minus V
No Moon
Leaderboard
Fillet
GetStatus
GetAd
GetCommit
A-M
InIt
SetBG
Fee
A-M
Hey deos funs
Wäre es nicht sogar smarter die Images auf GitHub
Suchen zu lassen aus dem repo raus, dann braucht man die nicht lokal kann easy immer welche hinzufügen
Ja, da muss man das kript halt ändern ich mein kann jeder machen was er will das ist jetzt nicht dafür
Ich habe das kript jetzt nicht da rein gehauen weil ich denke es sollte jeder verwenden sondern weil ich halt irgendein
Irgendeins braucht. By the way, ich habe ein error gefunden guck mal
Ein krümel ein krümel von dem hamburger ist durchsichtig und man sieht den pepo dahinter
Monke es
Transparenter burger krümel sesamsamen
Und der andere ist der eine ist blau einer ist grün
Completely unusable oder es ist gebadet
Wie macht man jetzt die größe da noch mal dahinter gar nicht oder da muss ich da muss ich mal kurz abgucken im vm champ
Da habe ich das nämlich gemacht mit der größe von den bildern in der ritmi
So habe ich das gemacht also quasi
geht das geht das so hey das funktioniert
ja dann ja dann machen wir es doch so dann machen wir es doch so
so und dann bauen wir uns jetzt einfach so was hier zusammen für für alle
boar i in du echo dollar i dann echo so wie muss das shit aussehen ok so muss es aussehen
alter habe ich mich vertippt so muss es aussehen
äh
muss ich auch noch eskapen
wie gehts
monka escape
dollare nice
so jetzt haben wir unsere ganzen
bilder am start
flesh script five fair time
nice
also no moon
die moons muss ich noch ausfiltern
die
oder habe ich die schon ausgefiltert
grad minus v
die muss man nicht anzeigen
die anzeigen
burger ist doppelt
so
jetzt haben wir noch alle bilder einmal drinne
jetzt müssen wir noch hinschreiben
images by
regman9
so
der sesam körner bug ist
behoben
das ging aber schnell
high speed
image fixing
so
massive
so ich star mich jetzt selbst
dann gehen wir nochmal auf
den burger
der burger hat jetzt keine durchsichtigen
sesam körner mehr
wo ist der burger
mit den sesam körnern
nice
sesam körner burger sind behoben
sehr schön
scanning for viruses
dann updaten wir das ganze mal
cp
downloads
so
ist das ausgetauscht
git pull origin master
minus minus rebase
dass wir die
achso
ok
kommet
fix burger
ok nice alles klar
passt
white people happy backgrounds für alle
porque
ich will jetzt
ich habe
eine
mal mit
da sword
der ist einmal mit
jadi kann man das eigentlich lassen
also für alle die schon immer mal white pepo happy backgrounds haben wollten jetzt könnt ihr euch
könnt also wie gesagt das das skript hier müsst ihr macht ja keinen sinn müsst ihr auch
überhaupt nicht verwenden hier ist der ordner mit den bildern drin und dem gefixten burger
den finde ich am besten der mit den bürgern so sieht er aus bevor er white pepo happy pepo
fat wird das muss man sich auch mal vorstellen das ist das ist ein satz den versteht außerhalb
von twitch wirklich keiner so sieht er aus bevor er pepo fat wird michael 50 milliarden
sagt man diesen satz versteht auf der welt niemand noch nicht mal auf twitch viel
ach dass das gefällt mir das gefällt mir das ist nice hat er eigentlich jetzt das
hintergrundbild geändert er müsste müsste er gleich machen
in
in zwei minuten müsste er das hintergrundbild ändern
und wahrscheinlich haben wir pech und er ändert das hintergrundbild auch aber es ist zufälligerweise
genau das gleiche und wir sehen es nicht irgendwie irgendwie gebetet er uns schon noch
ja nice ja das das das gefällt mir richtig gut ich glaube ich glaube die ritmi geht so
oder oder ihr ganzen 5 hat github ritmi schreiber soll ich dann soll ich da noch
irgendwas anderes reinschreiben ich meine ist doch eigentlich relativ relativ selbst erklärend
kommt das noch per hotfix damit das gleiche bild nicht zweimal kommt sehr gute idee pull requests
sind offen ist alles wirklich eine gute idee weil die bilder sind könnte man könnte man
glaube ich relativ relativ easy einbauen indem man hier einfach guckt welches background image
benutzt ist das reicht mir jetzt erst mal
das ist ein äußerst wichtiges projekt da muss ich erst mal meine pins customisieren
wo ist es? da war es doch
achso ich muss jetzt was anderes weg pinnen was pinne ich denn weg?
den epg champ den juckt keiner oder? den versandtracker
bei eigentlich kann ich keqv ss service auch weg weg machen
ein keqv ss service muss ja nicht wirklich da drin erstehen oder?
beste
zeit für eine retrospective er im moment wir haben noch nicht mal die
schiller tickets erstellt wie eigentlich ist wir konnten wir eigentlich hätte schon fertig
sein wir haben nichts agiles gemacht wir haben keine tickets aufgemacht kein daily scrum gehalten
und stand up und es ist trotzdem fertig geworden das ist doch eigentlich das geht doch eigentlich
eigentlich gar nicht keine geierer tickets keine gefahrenanalyse keine retrospective
kein sprintplanung und nix nix haben wir gemacht nix und das hat einfach funktioniert
achso ey background wechsel hat funktioniert leute
user stories brauchen wir noch richtig genau es ist 21 uhr also ist es jetzt nachtlaut im
script und er träumt von php ist das das php maskottchen
ist ja echtlich warum hat denn der so ein komisches schwanz
sieht aus als hat er jemand reingebissen oder ist ganz ausgefranst
es funktioniert
der auf dem hintergrund sieht glücklich aus ja ja der ist besser als der original als der
original p.a.p. elefant was denn das
ha leute der burger kam noch aus dem cache habt ihr das gesehen gecashter burger jetzt ist der
burger gefixt davor war er noch aus dem cache cached burger
ok dann gucken wir uns jetzt noch das hetzner das hetzner rz video an
hey leute und herzlich willkommen bei hardware deals heute zu einem sehr sehr spannenden video
denn wir wurden von hetzner eingeladen die stellen einen neuen server vor morgen und wir haben gefragt
ob wir das waren diese armen server die haben wir schon gesehen die tatsächlich ganz attraktiv
sind wenn man guten multi multi core workload hat und viel ram brauche ich einen tag vorher
das datacenter anschauen können wir sind heute in falkenstein das steht eins von hetzner nicht
nicht in nürnberg datacenter gibt es ja seit 1997 und die haben inzwischen wirklich sau viele
rechenzentren eins hier in falkenstein wo wir heute sind eins in nürnberg wir wissen genau dass es
nur im berg heißt und inzwischen auch mehrere standorte in den usa und das rechenzentrum in
falkenstein werden wir uns heute mal ein bisschen genauer anschauen echt wo haben sie noch in den
usa die haben ashwood hetzner usa ashwood heißt das doch glaube ich oder
datacenters wo haben sie denn noch was ash hillsboro das klingt das ohne scheiße ist
bestimmt zur richtigen hinterwelt stadt
so klein scheint es gar nicht zu sein oder
naja ich meine es ist riesengroß aber es ist jetzt keine ganz ganz kleines furz
also es ist nicht mini, ja, hillsbottles
ok roman also der bauer war ja auch schon mal hier das heißt manche sachen werdet ihr wahrscheinlich
auch wieder erkennen damals aus seinem video hier hinter mir seht ihr schon welche von den
datacentern und wie man sehen kann ist hier noch ein bisschen baustelle denn hier bei herzner
ich weiß nicht ob das schon fertig ist das neue datacenter aber ich bin auf jeden
fall gespannt ob wir da vielleicht auch mit einen blick sein dürfen weil wer auf jeden
fall spannend auch so im datacenter in der entsteung zu dürfen auf us lunar ist viel
klimaanlagen gebasteln dabei jeden fall ist hetzen einer der größten europäischen web poster mit
mehreren hundert tausend server die die cops und durante an produkten wirklich alles was man sich
in dem bereich vorstellen kann dedicated server cloud electricity anderes theme aber aufönig
auch gespannt und birgitt vielleicht noch einen anschauen können die machen web hosting es gibt
wie man kann cloud server anschauen das zerstört jetzt aber meine komplette illusion
server und die haben auch viele services wie ssl zertifikate oder auch einfach nur domain
registrierungen also bei hetzen wird wirklich alles aus diesem bereich geboten und ich bin mega
gespannt das ganze heute anschauen zu dürfen vor allem bin ich auch gespannt ob wir unseren
eigenen server hier wieder leider so paar sachen hätte ich also paar sachen fände ich noch ganz
gut als alternative also was ich was ich zum beispiel persönlich gerne sehen würde in zukunft also
es gibt es gibt eigentlich zwei sachen die ich in zukunft vielleicht noch gerne bei hetzen sehen
würde das eine wäre managt managt datenbacken möglichst billig ja also halt auf basis der
hetzener cloud vms nur dass es halt für mich mit ha und dem ganzen shit gehandelt wird sie
machen das ja jetzt schon mit load balancern allerdings ja so eine datenbank wäre auch nicht
verkehrt und vielleicht in zukunft auch ein managt kubernetes das wäre wirklich eine
coole kombination weil viele leute machen das schon selbst und das geht auch wunderbar auf
hetzener cloud vms das heißt es wäre tatsächlich gar nicht verkehrt wenn man das managt anbieter
ich verstehe aber dass sie zumindest managt kubernetes nicht machen wollen bzw auch managt
datenbanken da gehört halt schon einiges auch noch an know-how dazu und wenn man nicht aufpasst
kackt halt ab und man muss sich dann halt auch um die updates und alles kümmern genauso bei
datenbanken also ja ich verstehe aber das wäre tatsächlich zwei services die würden tatsächlich
würden hetzener noch ein bisschen rausstechen lassen weiter weil so richtig richtig günstig
das günstigste was mir so einfällt managt kubernetes und datenbanken ist digital ocean aber
tatsächlich dann hättst du noch mal so richtigen bust bringen weil dann können
man ist nicht irgendwelche super advance geschichten braucht ja wenn du jetzt irgendwie
chw sheets proبدס
also wenn du nicht diese super advanced sachen brauchst georeplizierung alles mögliche was
jetzt die die großen cloud anbieter anbieten dann wäre hetsna tatsächlich richtig gute
alternative wenn man sich nämlich überlegt dass bei google clouds somit mit der kleinstmögliche
kubernetes cluster kostet 70 euro im monat bei google und das sind glaube ich nur nur
zwei kleine notes drin da kannst du kaum was drauf laufen lassen sobald du einen
cluster laufen lassen willst der auch ein bisschen workload hat da bezahlst du mal
bestimmt 500 euro aufwärts
und insofern
hätte es durchaus seinen charm so für sagen wir mal
sagen wir mal 20 30 euro einstiegspreis oder 20 euro einstiegspreis dann halt vielleicht
vielleicht auch nur einen zwei bis drei noten cluster aus den allerkleinsten vms oder wie auch
immer also ja das wäre schon das wäre schon cool ohne mannage datenbank mannage postgres
wäre auch ultra nice weil nicht jeder hat das know-how und die zeit und den bock und will den
aufwand betreiben eine postgres datenbank hoch verfügbar in der cloud zu betreiben das wäre
cool und letztendlich die infrastruktur haben sie ja schon bei google ist es ja auch nicht anders
die google kubernetes cluster bestehen aus ganz normalen google vms und also gcp vms und die
mannage datenbanken sind auch ganz normale compute instances also das könnten die aber jetzt auch so
machen es ist im prinzip eigentlich nur in anführungen strichen quasi so in den ends
of the script was im hintergrund läuft und das professioniert für einen wobei mit nur ich sag
das absicht weil ist es natürlich nicht ja du musst das eben im web interface einbinden du
musst dich um updates kümmern du musst dich um security sagen das ist nicht nur aber du
könntest es automatisch professionieren lassen ja machst du ein wizard was weiß ich triple
notes da und davon im hintergrund wird es dann professioniert nach zehn minuten hast du dein
cluster wer extrem nice also mannage datenbanken mannage kubernetes wenn die sowas noch mal in
zukunft anbieten würden das wäre wirklich mega coole sache
und vielleicht in zukunft noch wenn sie wenn sie wenn sie das auch hinkriegen vielleicht noch
irgendeinen irgendeinen storage in den cloud in ein cloud native storage weil irgendwo musst
ja auch dein kubernetes zeug drauf laufen lassen das kannst natürlich mit local volumes machen was
aber auch nicht so der letzte weisheitssetzer schluss ist
irgendwas irgendwas ordentliche storage provider mäßiges für kubernetes noch
schlag das zeug vor ich habe mir in der startenbank schon vorgeschlagen aber das
wollten sie nicht machen also da haben sie gemeint das ist aktuell wäre das wäre das nicht geplant
unser server steht hier in falkenstein gut es aber auch schon wieder eineinhalb jahre her aber
wie gesagt ich ich kann es mir ungefähr ausmalen da hängt ja ein bisschen was hintendran
hetsna kannst du schon in terraform aufbauen das ist gar kein problem es gibt fix und fertige
terraform scripts die den kubernetes cluster bei hetsna professionieren und noch mehr gibt noch
mehr scripts dafür es ist relativ easy also es gibt ja schon fertige scripts dafür wenn man es
nicht selbst machen will und deswegen hetsna müsste es halt richtig machen dass im hintergrund
professioniert werden ich muss sagen dass web ich mag wirklich das web interface von der hetsna
cloud das ist schön schnell und simpel und funktional und lässt sich usability ist gut lässt sich gut
bedienen also ein schnelles webinterface würde ich mir auch mal für google oder oder azure
wünschen und machen aber halt auch eine ganze ecke noch mehr aber das hetsna web Interface ist
wirklich saumäßig schnell wie da was angelegt wird Kling球ião server ist da so hast ja kaum
Zeit auf die konsole zu switchen und pass das hdp zu copy paste an dieser server auch schon da
immer gespannt ob wir den wieder finden weil ich denke da ist schon eine ganz schöne anzahl an
servicern hier in diesem rechenzentrum auf jeden fall gibt es auch sonst jede menge spannende
themen die server werden hier auch zusammengebaut das werden wir uns auch mal anschauen und hier
ist immer weiter angebaut worden das heißt man kann auch so ein bisschen nachvollziehen wie
das angefangen hat und wie so ein rechenzentrum inzwischen aussieht und es gibt natürlich auch
viele spannende themen wie kühlung allgemein wie so ein server aufgebaut ist und vieles mehr ich
hätte gesagt wir gehen jetzt rein weil ist doch ziemlich kalt hier draußen wir sind hier genau an
der schneegrenze wo wir vorher losgefahren sind lag halt noch eine menge er patrick dankeschön
für den sub 46 monat das ist extrem michael wenn du keine ipv4 adresse hast wirst du dein natt
nicht offen bekommen aber macht doch auch nix der kram funktioniert mittlerweile doch auch so ich
mein seriously ich verstehe nicht warum call of duty damit jemals probleme hatte man kann
das doch ordentlich tunneln ja ok man konnte damals nicht mit seiner xbox hosten aber ansonsten
auch so doch gar nicht das geht doch das geht doch geht doch ohne probleme dass die anzeige ist
total hängen geblieben was macht er überhaupt kann also brauchst das gar nicht du verbindest
dich von dir zum server ach bei mw 2009 ja das ist richtig das stimmt wobei auf dem pc gibt
es da nicht richtige server ja das ist das ok da keine ahnung gibt es gibt es weiß ich aber nicht
wie gut das funktioniert
dedicated servers on all platforms
also je nachdem ich gehe davon aus dass die ihre rechten zentren jetzt nicht runterkühlen
auf 18 grad oder sowas aber da drinne wird wahrscheinlich was was werden auf was werden
die die klimaanlage eingestellt haben 23 grad 22 grad 23 grad der trend ging er die letzten
jahre eindeutig dahin dass man rechenzentren ein bisschen rechenzentren wieder ein bisschen
wärmer macht früher hat man die dinger immer krass auf 18 grad und so runter gekühlt auch
im sommer was halt ultra viel als mega viel energie gekostet hat und man hat sich gedacht
die bisschen geringere lebenszeit der kisten unter dem strich ist es halt überhaupt nicht
wert die energie ersparen ist also die energie kosten 23 straße in dem dreher also wir fahren
rein in den hoch sicherheitsdruck zieht euch das mal rein hier mit stacheldraht überall wir waren
gespannt ob man sich auch wiegen muss wie bei wie auf der hanau landstraße hier sind halt natürlich
darin drin, in den data sender und hardware natürlich und hardware deals gleich sehsam öffne dich
so also wir haben es jetzt inzwischen wieder aufwärmen können wir haben hier eine komplette
tour durchs rechenzentrum bekommen und ich kann euch sagen es werden auf jeden fall einige spannende
themen heute hier im video sein wir schauen uns einmal die verschiedenen arten von den servers an
dann werden wir über die kühlung sprechen wir werden über die stromversorgung sprechen das
ist auch ein sehr interessantes thema und anschließend kann ich euch auch noch ein
rechenzentrum zeigen was gerade im aufbau ist das denke ich ist auch sehr interessant und dann
schauen wir uns noch die produktion an und vieles mehr also hier wirds auf jeden fall einige themen
in dem video geben wir sind hier schon mal in einen der gange im rechenzentrum wir sehen könnt
stehen hier sehr viele midi towers das kennt ihr das ist quasi aber was fandest du besser ich fand
zehn angenehmer aber wenn aus elf hat was meine cpu angeht ein paar vorteile deswegen benutze ich
klassisches pc format ich denke die meisten pcs von euch sind auch in so einer landstraße wird man
echt gewogen ja also nicht bei hetzner hetzner ist wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich hat hetzner
auch ein paar router oder oder switches stehen in der hannover landstraße aber die haben doch kein
eigenes rechnzentrum also insofern ja du wirst gewogen wenn du da reingehst
mal hier ich zeige euch mal wo das ist maps google
hannauer landstraße frankfurt de
interaction genau
ja hier irgendwo unterirdisch ist das dann kann man das immer nicht genau merken wobei
ich dachte es ein bisschen weiter vorne hier ist der kentucky fried schicken
ein bisschen weiter wo wo es jetzt genau ist weiß ich gar nicht mehr so aus der vogel perspektive
weiß müller strass kommt mir hier hier
ich ich glaube hier irgendwie unter unterirdisch hier irgendwie so unterirdisch unterirdisch und
erster stock irgendwie hier so müsste das sein
ja und da wird man wird man gewogen wenn man reingeht tatsächlich ja
jepp
von wann ist das 2010 lull
hier sind sie natürlich nicht ja doch das kommt mir bekannt vor
hier musst du dich irgendwie anmelden ja ja das kommt mir bekannt vor
äh warum wird man gewogen dass du nicht sachen drinne ablädst und nicht wieder mit rausnimmst
komm aus hanau ja
in der kleiner straße da war ich auch schon
kleiner straße in fangfurt ich bin nix früher gab es da itinos oder so was die den eingang
gemacht haben und die hatten so eine furchtbar unfreundliche frau am eingang itinos in der
kleiner straße
ja ok guck mal weiter
midi tower drin interessanterweise ist hier sehr viel consumer hardware bei
also jetzt setzt in sehr vielen servern auf consumer hardware unter anderem der
grund dass diese hardware halt deutlich preiswerter als reine server hardware
und wenn den kram wegschmeißt und austauscht ist das wahrscheinlich der beste ansatz so zu fahren
was sagst du zu dem rechenzentrumsbau in Schöneck das soll ja angeblich auch...
keine ahnung nö haben ich nichts von mitgekriegt
von der leistung langlebigkeit und so weiter unterscheiden sich server hardware
und consumer hardware aber nicht großartig. midi tower sind eine von drei arten von
servern die hier bei herzner zum einsatz kommen es gibt die midi tower es gibt
19 zoll racks also der normale server standard und dann hat herzner auch noch
sein eigenes racksystem entwickelt warum die das gemacht haben und was
bevorteile das hat das werden wir uns später noch anschauen was ich auch sehr
interessant finde das mir gerade aufgefallen wir haben hier zum
beispiel noch einen eX 52 NVMe das ist genau der server den wir selber auch
benutzen also nicht das ist unser server aber der eX 52 so einen haben wir auch
und da ist unsere eigene homepage drauf gehostet und wir werden mal schauen ob
wir später noch unseren eigenen server hier finden werden wenn wir jetzt hier
gerade noch bei den midi towers stehen dann kann ich euch auch mal die kühlung
hier zeigen was ist der blaue dongel da ich vermute mal sowas wie kvm für dass
so dass du dich mit mit einer tastatur dran anstöpseln kannst ohne die
tastatur dahin tragen zu müssen es funktioniert nämlich so dass hier in
der mitte also quasi vor den midi towers wird kalte luft nach oben gepustet die
kommt von außen von außerhalb von den gebäuden werde ich ja später auch noch
zeigen und die wird dann vorne an den midi towers durch den lüfter donít
schaut dann seht ihr das habt ihr vielleicht vorher auch schon gesehen
als wir hier her gefahren sind im intro die dächer sind angewinkelt das sorgt
dafür dass die warme luft hier oben aufsteigt und bis nach da oben zieht
wo diese lamelln sind und da kann die luft lang bei fettkonstruktion sind oder
ob sie geöffnet sind kann sie entweder nach draußen
oder sie
das sind ja im endeffekt regale was selber drin stehen ja es ist ganz clever
gemacht
normalerweise hast du im ansatz hier oder was heißt normalerweise kann man so
nicht sagen
aber es kommt oft vor dass im rz quasi solche
solche abgekapselten gänge sind
das ist die warme seite das ist die kalte seite
meistens ist dann auch eine decke hier direkt drüber
am ende der schränke
dass du gerade so durchgehen kannst in der mitte
die müssen natürlich halt auch gucken dass das preis leistungsmäßig passt
ich finde es eine schlaue konstruktion
wird wieder vom klimasystem angezogen dazu werde ich jetzt gleich noch was
sagen
und im zweifelsfall kriegen die da auch noch mehr drauf wenn du noch eine reihe
mal sind auf der raustellen willst geht das wahrscheinlich auch das
klima system für uns am besten von oben an sich Spielmanns hat eine ganz schöne
raumhöhe hier
haben jetzt nach oben die st Tucson der ersten krischen noch weiter nach oben
hier
und ihr sehtustinger über lookout sogar wenn möglich
eine Menge Burger
und das ist nur eins von den Rechenzentren下來 wir in ste Protect
ngsın von diesen Rechenzentren also natürlich сам das Gacin fifa ins
gesamten rejections
dyr paintsur war upsein hier
was man hier unten auch sehen kann ist
dass hier eben nicht nur Meditator zum Einsatz kommen. Das was ihr hier unten
seht ist das Hezneriend eigene Wreck System. Die haben ihr eigenes Wreck System entwickelt
für ihre eigenen Ansprüche
warum genau kommen später noch zu, aber vor allem geht es auch um die Packdichte
denn ihr seht schon da passt natürlich viel mehr rein als wenn man
Medi Tower verwendet
die Packdichte ist 2,5 mal so hoch also man kriegt
wenn man das Wreck System von Hezner verwendet hat 2 Mal so viele Server
wie wenn man nur Medi Tower verwenden würde
die Kühlung von dem ganzen habe ich gerade eben schon angeschnitten
das ist eben so dass immer zwei Reihen von Medi Towers sich gegenüber stehen
und dann in der Mitte wird quasi kalte Luft nach oben gepustet beziehungsweise
von den Medi Towers angesaugt weil die ja auf beiden Seiten vorne einen Lüfter
drin haben und die warme Luft dann nach hinten rauspusten. Die kalte Luft die vorne
angesaugt wird die kommt von draußen
ihr seht schon hier an der Seite von dem Gebäude, ich arbeite nicht in Hanau, ne, ich bin in
ich arbeite in Frankfurt. Also das sind glaube ich 18 Stück pro Gebäude
jedes einzelne von diesen silbernen Kästen hier ist eine Klimaanlage
das interessante ist, dass hier erstmal komplett mit der Außenluft gearbeitet wird
interessanterweise wird hier nämlich 95 Prozent des Jahres nicht aktiv zugekühlt
oder zugehalzt. Das ganze funktioniert so, dass die Luft von außen eben hier
reingepustet wird und je nachdem was für eine Temperatur die hat, aktuell ist sie
ja ziemlich kalt, wir haben draußen irgendwie minus zwei Grad gehabt vorher, muss sie
auch aufgewärmt werden. Bei den Medi Towersystemen ist es so, dass die eine
Betriebstemperatur von 22 Grad haben, bei den Rex Systemen von 24 Grad, im Sommer
liegt die auch noch mal ein bisschen höher und dementsprechend wird die
warme Abluft, die hier hinten rauskommt aus den Systemen, vermischt mit der
Außenluft, um genau die Betriebstemperatur von den Servern zu erreichen.
Okay, das ist Sixhead, wenn sie das ordentlich reguliert bekommen.
Spart halt massig Geld für die Klimaanlage.
Kommt dann wieder die Klimaanlage ins Spiel, da sind unten Klimakompressoren
drin, draußen sind auch noch große Wärmetauscher und dann wird die Luft
eben zusätzlich runtergekühlt, das ist aber natürlich ein Riesenkostenfaktor,
wenn man ein komplettes Rechenzentrum, die Luft runterkühlen muss. Deswegen hat man hier auch
einen relativ kühlen Standort gewählt und eben, wie gesagt, 95% der Jahre wird nicht zusätzlich
gekühlt werden, sondern kann man einfach nur die Außenluft hier reinpusten.
Durch Zufall sind wir gerade hier dran noch vorbeigekommen, so sehen die
Radiallüfter aus, die in der Klimaanlage drin sind, also das sind schon echt
riesige Teile. Gesteuert wird das Ganze über diese Lamellen hier oben, wenn diese
Lamellen offen sind, dann kann die warme Luft nach draußen ziehen, wenn diese
Lamellen sich schließen, dann staut sich die Luft hier oben natürlich an, wenn man
hier mal nach unten schaut, dann sieht man nämlich die Oberseite von dieser
Klimaanlage und die kann eben, wie gesagt, die warme Luft, die sich schon hier drin
befindet, wieder ansaugen, mit der Außenluft vermischen und dann genau die
gewünschte Temperatur erreichen. Weil auch die Lamellen oben an dieser
Klimaanlage, oben an diesem Klimaschacht sind verstellbar und können eben geschlossen
oder geöffnet werden, je nachdem, ob die Luft mit der Außenluft vermischt werden soll.
Wir sind jetzt direkt ins nächste Rechenzentrum weitergewandert und hier
stehen schon ganz viele von den neueren REC-Systemen von Hetzner. Ihr seht es,
wenn wir mal von oben hier runter schauen, dass hier einfach wirklich eine
viel höhere Packdichte erreicht werden kann. Dann schaut euch mal an, wie viele
Server alleine in einer so einer Reihe drin sind. Das ist wirklich extrem und man
sieht auch schon, dass das Kühlkonzept hier sehr sehr ähnlich funktioniert.
Schauen wir uns jetzt aber noch mal aus der Nähe an. Wir sind jetzt mal nach unten
gegangen und ich stehe jetzt tatsächlich in einem von den Kühlgängen drin. Rechts
und links von mir sind die ganzen RECs, die ihr gerade eben von außen gesehen habt,
die vorne die Metallblende dran haben und so sieht das Ganze von der Rückseite
aus. Das Kühlkonzept ist wirklich nicht schlecht, also alles wirklich ordentlich.
Klar hast du immer noch so die super Kabelfetischisten, denen auch das nicht
reicht, aber da siehst du schon, da ist das Thema dahinter. Im Endeffekt liegt hier
halt irgendwie das Mainboard drinnen, so mehr oder weniger.
Sehr sehr interessant. Ihr seht, wir sind hier in einem geschlossenen Gang drin.
Über uns ist Glas oder Plexiglas, da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, aber es ist
Ja, so kenne ich das mit Gang drüber und Tür davor.
Hier unten, wenn man nach unten schaut, sieht man, hier sind so Lüftungsgitter und da wird
eben die kalte Luft von außen oder je nachdem die vermischte Luft hier nach oben gepustet,
beziehungsweise von den Servern eben. Ich fände es interessanter, wenn er die Kisten von hinten zeigt.
Jedes von diesen Rack-Systemen hat außen einen Lüfter und zieht die Luft entsprechend hier
durch, sodass hier ein Sog entsteht und eben die kalte Luft hier reingezogen wird. Muss ich auch sagen,
hier drin ist es temperaturmäßig ziemlich angenehm, verglichen mit draußen. Ich würde
mal schätzen, dass es hier in diesem rechten Zentrum so um die 30 Grad hat oder sowas und
hier drin so um die 20 Grad vielleicht wirklich sehr angenehm auf jeden Fall. Wenn man sich das
mal anschaut, dann sieht man eben auch wieder. Okay, ja, hier liegt so mehr oder weniger das
Mainboard drin. Und wisst ihr, das mag jetzt für den manch einen unordentlich aussehen,
aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher erstens, dass das alles System hat und zweitens,
dass das absichtlich so gebaut ist. Also ich gehe davon aus, das ist halt so gebaut,
dass du möglichst schnell auch Teile wechseln kannst, dass du nicht erst ausbauen musst,
aufschrauben musst, also sprich, du kannst nach Möglichkeit alles, sofern man dran kommt,
austauschen hier ohne die Kiste kurz auszubauen und sowas. Die scheinen ja auch keine Schienen
zu haben. Das ist halt so auf Effizienz gemacht.
Auf den ersten Blick, hier passt wahnsinnig viel mehr rein, als wenn man Midi-Tower verwendet.
Ja, hier muss man natürlich ein bisschen aufpassen beim Ziehen, dass man nicht den
einen selber mit rauszieht, wenn man den unteren rauszieht.
Hier sind 24 Systeme pro Reihe.
Bin ich gut gemacht.
Ich meine, zieht es euch rein, das will ich jetzt nicht nachzählen,
aber das sind einige Reihen hier drin.
Ich habe mir sagen lassen, das sind insgesamt über 1.400 Systeme, die in einem so einem
Kühlgang stehen. Also das ist wirklich extrem, wie eng man diese Systeme dann unterbringen kann.
Wir haben die ganze Tour ja schon bekommen und ich kann euch sagen, ich kann euch nachher zeigen,
wie sowas gebaut wird. Das ist nämlich mega spannend, denn die gesamten Rahmen,
die gesamte Rack-Konstruktion hier wird von Hetzner selber an diesem Standort hier gebaut.
Und dann können wir eben sehen, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Ja, das sind halt Blech-Schränke, was aber auch gut spart halt letztendlich auch Geld.
Du kriegst halt so nicht fertig gekauft.
Das wird nämlich aus einzelnen Modulen zusammengesetzt, das ist komplett modular,
das kann hier überall aufgestellt werden. Und das Interessante ist auch der Boden.
Wenn man hier unten durchschaut, dann sieht man, wir sind quasi ein Meter über dem eigentlichen Boden
von dem Rechenzentrum. Also die gesamte Fläche von der Halle.
Ja, so Doppelboden ist eigentlich vollkommen normal im RZ.
Wie ihr gerade eben gesehen habt, wir waren ja oben, das ist eine riesige Halle,
die ist ein Meter nach oben gesetzt worden, mit solchen Stelzen,
das unten komplett kalte Luft ist, also unter dieser gesamten Halle...
Ja, und vor allem, dass man im Zweifel was drunter verlegen kann,
das ist aber eigentlich normal im RZ, das ist eigentlich so gut wie immer doppelter Boden.
...kalte Luft durchgepustet, entsprechend kann man auch überall in dieser Halle
so einen Kühlgang aufbauen.
Ich frage mich, wie sie das mit den Kabeln gemacht haben, ob die unten durchgehen
und ob sie oben irgendwelche Trassen haben.
Aber man hat ja eben das Ganze in der Halle gesehen, da war nichts.
Also ich vermute mal, es geht auch unten durch den Boden zum größten Teil der Kabel.
Das ist wirklich mega clever gemacht.
Wie genau das aussieht mit diesem, ich nenne es mal doppelten Boden,
kann ich euch nachher zeigen.
Ist ein Meter auch normal oder ist das normal?
Es ist normal, glaube ich, ein bisschen weniger.
Ich habe mir das noch nie so im Detail angeguckt.
Also doppelter Boden ist ziemlich normal im Rechenzentrum.
Aber ich glaube, Meter vielleicht eher nicht.
Hier ist gerade ein Rechenzentrum, was neu gebaut wird.
Was ich auch noch sehr interessant fand, die Information habe ich auch vorher noch bekommen,
diese Eigenentwicklung von den Racksystemen,
die hatten nicht nur den Grund, dass man das Ganze ein bisschen enger packen kann,
sondern es hat auch was mit dem Energieverbrauch zu tun.
Das ist eine komplette Eigenentwicklung, auch mit den Lüftern hier.
Das dachte ich mir.
Und das soll auch günstige Kombination, günstige Hardware,
Strom sparen und möglichst viel auf einen engen Raum.
Dann als wenn man irgendwie so ein Midi-Tower oder einen fertigen 19 Zoll Server nimmt.
Und was man hier auf der Rückseite auch noch schön sieht, sind eben die ganzen kleinen Lüfter,
die hier an jedem Racksystem dran sind.
Da habe ich gerade eben schon von gesprochen.
Also man braucht hier nicht viel Druck, um die Luft hier wirklich rein zu pusten,
sondern die Server, die saugen die kalte Luft quasi raus.
Die saugen sozusagen.
Also wenn man die Hand dahin hält, ist schon ordentlich warm, was da rauskommt.
Was ihr hier hinter mir seht, sind jetzt die ganz normalen, typischen 19 Zoll-Systeme.
Die benutzt Hetzner.
Schlafender Azubis im Doppelboden, okay, das habe ich noch nie gesehen in irgendeiner Zeit.
Für Kundensysteme, aber zum Beispiel auch für die Hetzner Cloud.
Haben die kein redundantes Netzteil?
Schaut nicht so aus.
Aber muss man ja auch nicht unbedingt.
Wobei, warte mal.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Aber muss man ja auch nicht unbedingt.
Wird halt ausgetauscht, wenn es kaputt ist.
Spart Geld und Strom und Wärme und alles.
Und so oft gehen ja Netzteile nicht kaputt.
Ich meine, bei der Menge.
Ja, bei der Menge.
Vielleicht haben die auch auf der anderen Seite noch eins.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber trotzdem, bei der Menge geht trotzdem täglich laufen was kaputt.
Ja, also ist ja klar, wenn du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 10.000 Systeme hast und du auch nur
einen 0,01 Ausfall da hat, da ist halt auch trotzdem am Tag immer mal was kaputt.
Was ihr hinter mir seht, sind jetzt die ganz normalen, typischen 19 Zoll Systeme.
Die benutzt Hetzner für Kundensysteme, aber zum Beispiel auch für die Hetzner Cloud.
Also hier in diesen rechten Zentren gibt es alles.
Midi Tower Systeme, die eigenen Wrecksysteme von Hetzner, aber eben auch 19 Zoll Systeme.
Wir sind jetzt auch mal hier in den Kühlgang reingegangen.
Was auffällig ist, ist, dass es hier drin nochmal...
Das sind, das sind, das sieht jetzt eher nach normalen Servern aus.
Mit ein bisschen ordentlich Storage drin, hä?
Ordentlich Storage Kram.
Was hier deutlich lauter ist, als bei den eigenen Wrecks von Hetzner,
das liegt vor allem daran, dass diese 19 Zoll Systeme halt so winzig kleine Lüfter verwenden.
Habt ihr grad eben schon außen gesehen und die drehen halt viel, viel höher.
Dadurch, dass diese kleinen Lüfter halt auch so extrem hoch drehen,
ist es so, dass die Systeme auch deutlich mehr Strom verbrauchen.
Man unterschätzt es, wie viel Strom so ein kleiner Lüfter verbrauchen kann.
Ich hab mir sagen lassen, dass teilweise so ein kleiner Lüfter bis zu 60 Watt Strom verbrauchen kann.
Also teilweise ist es bei Servern so, dass der Lüfter mehr Strom verbraucht,
als der eigentliche Server an sich.
Das ist eben auch einer der Gründe, warum Hetzner seine eigenen Wrecks entwickelt hat,
um diese Stromverbrauchung zu minimieren.
Jetzt ist hier einer ordentlich durchgestartet neben mir.
Okay, gehen wir aber weiter.
Was auch noch ein sehr interessantes Thema ist,
ist natürlich die Stromversorgung von dem Ganzen,
weil so viele Server verbrauchen natürlich auch eine Menge Strom.
Ein Rechenzentrum alleine verbraucht 1,2 Megawatt
oder ist auf 1,2 Megawatt spezifiziert.
Das sind 1,2 Millionen Watt, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Und das ist eben so ausgelegt,
dass es bei durchschnittlicher Auslastung der Fall ist.
Wenn man jetzt mal überlegen würde,
wenn jeder Server hier zu 100% ausgelastet wäre,
dann wäre das natürlich noch mal deutlich mehr,
aber in der Realität kommt das natürlich gar nicht vor.
Trotzdem, wir haben hier 18 Rechenzentren,
jedes davon 1,2 Megawatt,
das ist schon wirklich eine ganz schöne Hausnummer.
Da jedes Rechenzentrum aber ja die gleiche Grundfläche hat
und die gleiche Größe und 1,2 Megawatt quasi die Obergrenze sind,
versucht man die Rechenzentren
so effizient wie möglich auszustatten.
Das heißt, man mischt Midi-Tower
mit diesen eigenen Rack-Systemen und mit 19 Zoll-Systemen.
Die haben ja alle eine andere Packdichte, um die Fläche eben so gut...
Das Wort Packdichte gefällt eben, oder?
...möglich auszunutzen.
Denn wenn man nur die eigenen Rack-Systeme verwenden würde,
die eine extrem hohe Packdichte haben,
dann würde halt die alte Fläche leer stehen.
Thema Stromversorgung ist in einem Rechenzentrum
besonders wichtig und da nicht ausgeschlossen werden kann,
dass der Strom halt auch mal ausfällt oder die Spannung abfällt,
sind hier natürlich riesige USVs verbaut.
Die sorgen im Notfall dafür,
dass das gesamte Rechenzentrum
bis zu 15 Minuten weiterhin mit Strom versorgt werden kann.
Und falls ihr euch fragt, was...
15 Minuten ist ganz schön lang.
Was passiert nach den 15 Minuten?
Dann geht ein Dieselgenerator an.
Wir haben auch noch einen riesigen Dieselgenerator,
der bis zu drei Tage lang...
Dir gefällt das Wort Exzellent.
Mehrwatt, aber Exzellent ist auf jeden Fall dabei.
Wenn man Strom versorgen kann, den werden wir uns gleich auch noch anschauen.
Exzellent.
Hier hängen auf jeden Fall riesige Batterien dran.
Die zeige ich euch jetzt.
Hier sind wir jetzt im Batterieraum und ihr seht schon...
Das haben wir schon mal beim Bauer gesehen vor zwei Jahren oder so.
... für 15 Minuten leisten zu können.
Die 15 Minuten sind auch absolut ausreichend,
weil es eben diesen Dieselgenerator gibt.
Der braucht so um die 20 Sekunden zum Anlaufen.
Also hier wurde alles wirklich ausreichend bedacht.
Und wenn man sich das mal anschaut bei diesen Zellen hier,
du kannst ja mal reinkommen,
das sind alles riesige 2 Volt-Zellen,
die in Reihe geschaltet sind.
Und die sind auch durchnummeriert.
Das sind insgesamt 240 Stück hier pro Regal.
Das heißt, das USV arbeitet mit 480 Volt.
Also hier stehen wir jetzt vor allem von den Dieselgeneratoren.
Das ist ein 16-Zylinder-Diesel-Aggregat.
Und es kann zwei Meter...
Das ist bestimmt sowas, was sie sonst im U-Boot haben.
... also nochmal deutlich mehr,
als ein Rechenzentrum benötigen würde.
Wobei...
Ich glaube sowas haben die nicht im U-Boot, oder?
Wie das Rechenzentrum hat so ein Teil.
Also hier ist schon wirklich für Stromversorgung selbst im absoluten Notfall gesorgt.
Das Ganze läuft dann für zwei bis drei Tage komplett autark.
Da hinten sind riesige Tanks,
mit insgesamt 60.000 Litern.
Die sind aber jeweils für zwei Aggregate,
also stehen 30.000 Liter Diesel für ein Aggregat im Notfall bereit.
Was wir hier draußen jetzt auch sehen können,
sind eben diese riesigen Wärmetauscher,
die, wenn es mal wirklich warm draußen wird...
Das haben wir beim Bauer auch schon gesehen.
... dass die Klimaanlage drin, die Temperatur runterkühlen kann.
Und genau dafür sind die eben da.
Und das ist das, was wir hier sehen.
Das ist das, was wir hier sehen.
Und genau dafür sind die eben da.
Aber wie gesagt, 95% des Jahres laufen die sowieso nicht.
Wir sind jetzt gerade in einer der Hallen, die im Aufbau ist.
Und ihr seht hinter mir, das finde ich sehr interessant,
das ist so ein Racksystem im Aufbau quasi.
...
Hey, bei Hetzner kann man sich doch auch so Co-Location-mäßig einmieten, ha?
Was kostet denn das eigentlich?
...